but here's what I'm
doing real if I may uni streets no in my
20s Asians weren't
in in the 90s dude we weren't in we were
out like we were like we get me like and
black black dudes loved Asian women
white dudes Lov Asian women so you guys
took our women but you guys never gave
us your women back we were all alone in
the 90s dude all shaking we were shaking
you know
we we were we depleted a I
think that I think that sh were no you
guys depleted us from when did
when did Jet Lee do the movie with
Aaliyah in early 2000s exactly that
changed the game I know but I'm talking
about the 90s we were we were in the
Dark Ages but that's also Jet Lee that's
Jet Lee too yeah but but hold on
but but Jet Lee